bien Mesdames et Messieurs chers amis
journalistes qui est en relation par
visio et ceux qui sont présents bien sûr
je suis heureux de vous saluer et de et
de vous remercier d'avoir accepté de
partager ces quelques instants pour
revenir pour revenir sur cette loi de
programmation militaire qui va trouver
ici au Sénat demain sa conclusion
définitive par l'adoption je l'espère
des conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est tenue lundi avant
tout je voudrais
saluer le travail parlementaire qui a
été effectué au sein de cet assemblée
vous vous souvenez que nous n'avions pas
retenu la proposition
du ministre de de participer à des
groupes de travail de 60 à 80
participants certainement des
personnalités tout à fait honorables
mais ne nous paraissait pas que le
travail pouvait être effectué dans les
meilleures conditions et donc
avec l'aide de mes rapporteurs adjoints
essentiellement du reste les rapporteurs
budgétaires
de la commission qui connaissent nos
forces armées depuis des années et qui
suivent son activité avec
beaucoup d'intérêts beaucoup d'attention
et bien avec ces rapporteurs adjoints
nous avons pu faire un travail
préparatoire à la Commission et donc je
veux avoir une pensée pour ces 11
rapporteurs délégués qui m'ont bien
évidemment beaucoup aidé et assister
dans l'élaboration de la position du
Sénat sur laquelle je vais revenir par
ailleurs je voudrais souligner qu'ici au
Sénat il y a eu un très large consensus
au sein des différents groupes je pense
bien sûr aux républicains mais je veux
aussi saluer le groupe de nos collègues
socialistes qui a été à la fois très
constructif au cours de la discussion
mais aussi dans les moments toujours un
petit peu plus compliqué de la
commission mixte par faire ça lui aussi
l'Union centriste le RDC les
indépendants et même
nos collègues du groupe communiste et
j'ai souhaité tout au long de cette
discussion et avec le avec la volonté de
donner à chacun la possibilité de
participer à la construction de ce
document
législatif très important et donc c'est
ce qui nous avait permis notamment dans
la première phase de retenir un certain
nombre d'amendements de chaque groupe
pour bien souligner encore une fois
l'importance du travail collectif enfin
avant de d'en venir à l'essentiel de mon
propos je voudrais avoir aussi une
pensée amicale pour nos collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale notamment mon
collègue président Thomas gassillou et
aussi le rapporteur Jean-Michel Jacques
et avec Savine Tillet bien sûr pour la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons pu faire un travail
à la fois respectueux des positions de
chacun mais qui nous a permis d'aboutir
que des péripéties comme il peut
toujours y en avoir mais je rappelle que
mettre au point une enveloppe de 413
milliards n'est pas chose facile donc il
était assez normal qu'il y ait quelques
quelques discussions approfondie qui
nous ont occupé une bonne partie du
week-end alors maintenant sur le fond je
voudrais souligner ce qui a déjà été
rapporté par un certain nombre de
dépêche de presse en tous les cas la
manière dont le Sénat a souhaité donner
en quelque sorte sa marque je dirais de
manière un petit peu rapide mettre sa
patte sur le sur le texte pour
y apporter des éléments qui nous
paraissaient essentiels nous l'avions
fait précédemment j'avais eu l'honneur
d'être déjà rapporteur de la première
loi de programmation militaire et à
chaque fois le Sénat essaye par la
qualité de son travail de donner un peu
plus de de profondeur et une visibilité
plus plus claire des ambitions de cette
voie de programmation militaire
l'essentiel de notre travail a consisté
à solliciter du gouvernement une
accélération immédiate le plus rapide
possible dans tous les cas des crédits
supplémentaires afin de répondre à la
fois un contexte géopolitique
particulièrement
grave et inquiétant évidemment en
relation avec les événements du crâne et
puis aussi conduire le gouvernement à
éclaircir la présentation budgétaire
qu'il avait fait ce qui ne nous semblait
pas
ce qui nous emballait pas d'une clarté
absolue vous souvenez que à
Mont-de-Marsan le président de la
République a présenté une loi de
programmation militaire à 413 milliards
qui se subdivisaient en 400 milliards de
crédit de paiement en quelque sorte de
d'argent budgété et puis 13 milliards
qui eux-mêmes ce ventilait en 5 milliard
9 de recettes extra budgétaires mais à
peu près identifié je pense au ventes
immobilières je pense aux produits de
l'activité
médicale des hôpitaux militaires je
pense aux ventes de fréquences et
d'autres quelques dépenses quelques
quelques crédits que l'on pouvait
identifier et puis à cela se sur Ajouter
pour faire les 13 milliards 7 milliards
3 ou 7 milliards 4 qui eux
ne correspondaient véritablement pas à
des recettes budgétaires on les a
présentés comme étant les reports de
charge et les marges frictionnelles et
derrière ces termes tout à fait abscons
se cache effectivement ce qui se passera
sûrement c'est-à-dire des retards de
programme car une loi de une loi de
programme sur 7 ans n'est évidemment pas
prévisible à l'euro près mais vous savez
que de tout temps le Sénat a été et
reste très attentif à tout ce qui relève
des recettes extra budgétaires
c'est-à-dire de promesses qu'on a
beaucoup de mal à tenir puisque les
recettes en fait ne sont pas
ident en revanche comme je viens de le
dire ce que nous voulions c'était que
les la mise à niveau de nos forces
armées notamment pour tout ce qui
concerne la mise en condition
opérationnelle c'est-à-dire concrètement
l'entraînement de nos forces les
formations toute la logistique qui
entoure la mise en œuvre de de
nos disponibilités nous souhaitons bien
évidemment que ces crédits augmentent
bien sûr mais augmente le plus
rapidement possible c'est-à-dire dès
2024 alors qu'initialement le
gouvernement avait préparé une loi de
programmation militaire qui reprenait en
quelque sorte l'actuel loi je rappelle
que l'actuel loi prévoit une dépense de
l'ordre de 3 milliards par an et là les
annuités que nous présentait jusqu'en
2027 c'était toujours 3 milliards par an
ce qui fait que nous avons dû répondre à
nombreuses questions de notre collègue
qui disaient mais à quoi sert une loi de
programmation militaire nouvelle si
c'est pour dépenser la même chose et
donc la l'essentiel de notre réflexion
portait justement sur cette nécessité
de d'apporter une réponse à cette grande
difficulté de nos forces armées je donne
et j'ai eu l'occasion de donner au cours
du débat quelques exemples qui
permettent de mieux toucher la réalité
on a par exemple quatre régiments de
Charles blindé Leclerc et ils sont les
uns et les autres en fait à 50 % de leur
activité car quand il manque pas des
munitions il manque une entretien et
quand on a les munitions d'entretien on
a on n'a pas le on n'a pas le char à
disposition de la même manière on
s'aperçoit que par exemple sur le
pilotage des rafales on a un niveau
d'entraînement tout à fait insuffisant
puisqu'on est de l'ordre de 120 ou 130
heures alors que la norme au temps est
de 220 ce qui fait que normalement une
bonne partie du temps de ces pilotes
doit être sûrement d'attendre dans des
salles pour voir s'ils ont la
possibilité de voler s'ils ont le
kérosène si l'on apparaît disponible
donc on voit bien concrètement que ceci
pose des graves difficultés à un moment
où la France a besoin comme les pays
occidentaux de mobiliser toutes ses
forces car personne ne sait aujourd'hui
comment tourneront comment tournera
l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine et
donc il faut que plus que j'amène nos
forces armées soit les plus
opérationnelles possible et donc une
bonne partie de la discussion que nous
avons eu jusque tard dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi
dans les réunions
ultimes de concertation avant la CMP
elle-même tout l'objectif était
effectivement d'obtenir les efforts
nécessaires nous l'avions obtenu dans un
premier temps à hauteur de 2 milliards
sur les années 24 25 26 et 27 les quatre
premières années et nous avons considéré
que 2 milliards n'étaient pas suffisants
et donc nous avons noué cette discussion
avec les interruptions de séance que ce
genre de pratique nécessite et au final
grâce du reste à l'intervention du
président du Sénat qui a lui-même qui a
lui-même contacté la première féministe
nous avons pu obtenir une rallonge et
donc c'est à 2 milliards 300 millions de
crédit supplémentaires pour les quatre
années 2024 25 26 que nous allons mettre
à disposition des forces armées à
travers les exercices budgétaires qui
vont se suivre puisque évidemment une
loi de programmation budgétaire ne vit
qu'à travers les budgets successifs qui
permettent ça réalisation et donc
chemin faisant nous avons pu lever en
quelque sorte de paradoxes le premier
que que j'ai évoqué sur lequel je
reviens à l'instant c'est la
clarification de la trajectoire
budgétaire puisqu'encore une fois on
nous proposait des recettes qui étaient
qui n'existaient pas en vérité pour
parler à un langage simple qui pourront
peut-être exister je les reports de
charge existent systématiquement et on
nous a cité à juste titre le fait que
l'actuel loi de programmation militaire
qui est parti à 200 qui est parti à 196
milliards se terminera à 302 303 ou 3304
ce n'est pas tout à fait étonnant mais
nous ce que nous voulons c'est
effectivement nous voulions que ce
document soit le plus proche de la
réalité possible et donc là nous avons
eu de longues discussions des soirées
entières avec le gouvernement qui nous
expliquait que c'était pas des recettes
mais on était tout de même alors on a on
a dû composer pour nous notre idée était
de revenir assez 400 milliards de
crédits de paiement et tout au long de
la discussion alors même qu'on a pu nous
dire tenter de nous convaincre que l'on
voulait augmenter les crédits tels
n'étaient pas notre notre souhait notre
souhait était de bien préciser qu'elles
étaient la quelle était la portée de
cette loi de programmation militaire et
puis ce que nous voulions aussi c'est de
ne pas avoir des effets de courbes qui
s'aplatissaient ou qui
s'enfonçaient ou qui marquaient un faux
plat nous souhaitions avoir d'une
manière générale une progression la plus
constante possible et c'est ce à quoi
globalement nous sommes arrivés puisque
dès 2024 ce sont trois milliards 300
millions qui seront dépensés de la même
manière en 2025 et je dois dire ces deux
années sont pour nous absolument
essentiels elles sont cumulatives c'est
à dire que les 300 millions de 2024
s'additionneront à cette 25 et nous
continuerons 3 milliards
27 et puis après on passera à 3
milliards 6 donc les forces sera
continuent car ce que nous voulions
c'est que c'est le V l'idée selon
laquelle le gouvernement actuel
repoussait à 2027 qui comme par hasard
je crois doit être l'année de l'élection
présidentielle on ne considérait comme
quelque chose de pas tout à fait sincère
de reporter l'effort à un nouveau un
nouvel environnement politique un
nouveau président de la République donc
c'est ce qui a été compris en tous les
cas par le gouvernement puisqu'encore
une fois la la courbe a été modifiée
voilà donc j'allais dire pour
l'essentiel de l'apport du Sénat c'est à
dire cette volonté d'augmenter
immédiatement les qui vont permettre une
mise en condition opérationnelle
beaucoup plus rapide beaucoup plus
efficace je le mets du reste en toile de
fond de la situation en matière de
relations humaines au sein des armées
car là aussi c'est un véritable souci
tout le monde commence ici ou là la
définit non seulement la défidélisation
c'est-à-dire le fait que des des
militaires quittent les armées assez
prématurément mais aussi le fait l'autre
fait que par exemple 1500 postes
budgétaires ont été ouverts au sein des
armées et seulement 700 ont été ont été
occupés par de nouveaux recrutements ce
qui montre que les carrières militaires
notamment dans les parties les plus
technologiques les plus pointues sont
beaucoup moins attractifs
que ce que l'on souhaiterait et donc ça
c'est un véritable sujet donc 2
milliards 300 millions de crédit de 2024
à 2027 c'est-à-dire une accélération
très forte de l'argent que nous allons
mettre à disposition des armées pour
s'entraîner se former s'équiper et donc
ça c'est un point important
le deuxième axe de notre intervention
visait à renforcer le contrôle
parlementaire parce qu'en effet nous
devons porter ce lien entre le
gouvernement ces décisions et l'opinion
publique 4113 milliards par les temps
qui courent ce n'est pas une petite
affaire et donc il est absolument
nécessaire que nous puissions mieux
contrôler le
dispositif annuel des dépenses et
c'était notre exigence d'obtenir de la
part du gouvernement chaque année ce que
l'on appelle les chroniques de commandes
et les livraisons de matériel
c'est-à-dire concrètement quels sont les
matériels qui sont commandés et de telle
sorte de pouvoir suivre cette évolution
et voir si ça correspond bien à nos
orientations alors nous avons fait un
pas vers le gouvernement qui ne
souhaitait pas pour des raisons assez
compréhensibles que ces chroniques
budgétaires affichent les prix parce que
bien évidemment il y a à la fois
l'exportation et puis la relation avec
les industriels qui doit évidemment
donner au gouvernement tous les moyens
d'agir mais donc nous avons réussi à
d'avancer que nous n'a que l'on nous
avait promis déjà sous la loi de
programmation militaire précédente du
temps de la prédécesseur de Monsieur le
Cornu mais qui manifestement
n'avait pas fait l'objet d'une d'une
pratique réelle et nous avions du reste
soulevé ce problème lors du la petite
tension que nous avions vécu en 2021 je
crois avec la ministre des armées de
l'époque sur ces documents encore une
fois si on veut que les parlementaires
portent le message message fort d'une
telle dépense il faut que l'on puisse
justifier et contrôler
l'ensemble des commandes ce qui le rôle
somme toute du Parlement dans cette
affaire et puis nous avons pu
négocier et obtenir de la part du
gouvernement quelques avancées
importantes je pense à la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement dont j'ai
le nerf de faire d'assurer la
vice-présidence c'est délégation
parlementaires aux renseignements se
voyait régulièrement refusé d'aborder
dans ses débats les sujets d'actualité
et nous n'avions pas les auditions que
nous souhaitions nous disait que il
fallait ne travailler que sur des
événements postérieurement au temps où
ils étaient accompli et il nous semble
que l'actualité en matière de
renseignement est-elle est suffisamment
riche et parfois suffisamment
inquiétante pour que nous puissions bien
évidemment obtenir ces renseignements
ceci a été a été accordé enfin sur ce
sur ce deuxième point du contrôle
parlementaire c'est certainement l'une
des avancées les plus marquantes c'est
l'affaire des exportations d'armes les
ventes d'armes vous le savez font
l'objet régulièrement de d'enquête et de
la part de médias qui ou d'où NG qui
légitimement s'intéresse sur le point de
savoir si le Parlement peut effectuer un
contrôle ou une évaluation de ces de ces
exportations d'armes
je rappelle le système actuel qui
fonctionne c'est licences sont accordées
par la sienne je qui est un organisme
interministériel dépendant du Premier
ministre et qui donne ou ne donne pas
les licences nous ne siègeons évidemment
pas et nous n'avons aucune vocation ni
aucune volonté de participer à ce
travail qui relève des compétences de
l'exécutif ce que nous voulions c'est
aller un tout petit peu plus loin
puisque contrairement à tout ce qui se
passe dans bien d'autres pays nous
recevons chaque année un rapport assez
modeste somme toute qui ne donnent pas
la véritable la véritable perception de
ce qui se fait en matière de licence et
donc j'avais moi-même
j'étais confronté en tant que rapporteur
à plusieurs amendements qui visaient
carrément à instituer une délégation
parlementaire aux exportations d'armes
personnellement je n'y suis pas
favorable parce que respectueux de la
Constitution je pense effectivement que
ce domaine relève de l'exécutif mais
nous avions afin de de trouver on a un
consensus avec les différents groupes
qui avaient présenté ces amendements
j'avais je m'étais engagé à déposer un
amendement qui utilisait la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement et qui
faisait en quelque sorte de la DPR le
réceptacle d'une information du
Parlement bon le Parlement le
gouvernement n'était pas favorable à
cette solution et donc nous avons
négocié une un premier pas qui me semble
quand même tout à fait essentiel puisque
va être institué une commission
parlementaire d'évaluation de la
politique d'exportation d'armement ça
n'a jamais existé dans notre pays elle
sera composée de trois députés et de
trois sénateurs toujours bien évidemment
tenus aux règles de confidentialité que
ce genre de sujet nécessite et elle sera
présidée à alternativement par les deux
présidentes de commission de la défense
de nos deux assemblées et donc c'est je
dois dire que le gouvernement a été
assez réticent jusqu'au dernier jusqu'au
dernier moment de la négociation et
c'est un apport tout à fait conséquent
du Sénat puisque je rappelle qu'il y
avait eu une proposition de loi de
l'Assemblée nationale
qui n'avait pas qui n'avait pas pu
aboutir et c'est un premier point donc
que nous considérons comme assez positif
car l'affaire des exportations d'armes
est un sujet sur laquelle sur lequel le
Parlement doit bien évidemment pouvoir
porter un jugement expose mais en tous
les cas
de avoir des moyens d'une évaluation de
cette politique sachant que nous ne
sommes pas là pour le contrôler et que
ça reste bien évidemment une compétence
gouvernementale le troisième axe
concernait le financement de la BITD
vous savez que
à la fois par la conjugaison des règles
de taxonomie et de frilosité du système
bancaire français les n'ont pas les
grands groupes industriels mais les
petites et moyennes entreprises qui sont
très souvent sur des niches
excessivement technologiques qui
nécessitent de faire des investissements
très poussés très coûteux ne trouve pas
la réponse bancaire la réponse en
moyenne financiers qui qui est adéquate
et alors que nous avons absolument
besoin de maintenir ses investissements
et donc leur financement bancaire et
c'est ce pourquoi à l'initiative de
notre collègue Pascal alizat avait été
proposé un système qui a fait couler un
petit peu d'encre du côté de Bercy un
livret de souveraineté c'est à dire à la
manière du Livret de Développement
Durable la possibilité d'intéresser les
Français et les Français à leur propre
sécurité en investissant à la hauteur de
leurs moyens et sur la base du
volontariat cela va sans dire un peu
d'argent sur ces et moyennes entreprises
qui ont absolument besoin de financement
de la part d'un système bancaire qui
semble leur refuser alors
inutile de vous dire que ça a créé
beaucoup de discussions d'abord parce
que la vocation de la commission des
affaires étrangères et la défense n'est
pas de mettre en place des systèmes
financiers en tous les cas de les
décrire dans leur détail donc ça aurait
donné lieu à des décrets d'application
mais on nous a posé toutes sortes
d'arguments y compris celui qui nous
taxait de vouloir porter atteinte au
financement du logement social à travers
le livret A ce qui est évidemment hors
de proportions avec le projet tel que
nous proposons alors finalement voyant
qu'il y avait là un point de blocage
mais que nous voulions avancer nous
sommes convenus de faire un premier pas
en acceptant donc en proposant donc une
modification du code monétaire et
financier pour permettre le financement
par l'intermédiaire du livret A à des
entreprises de souveraineté ce qui va
permettre sur la masse du livret A et à
du proportion des besoins bien
évidemment de pouvoir aider les
entreprises de défense
explicitement viser comme tel le Sénat
insisté sur le point de bien préciser
les entreprises de défense nous avons
fait en sorte que ces entreprises de
défense puissent bénéficier d'une partie
du livret A je rappelle que le livret A
c'est plus de 375 milliards de rôles
n'avons pas l'intention de tous cet
argent sur les petites et moyennes
entreprises mais au moins c'était c'est
amendement était comme un appel pour
dire on ne peut pas laisser continuer
cette situation qui est évidemment tout
à fait inquiétante pour les petites et
moyennes entreprises qui régulièrement
nous saisissent et nous demande
d'intervenir auprès des
auprès des banques et c'est à l'état de
prendre ce sujet à bras le corps c'est
l'État qui a les moyens je rappelle
qu'il a quand même la tutelle de la
Banque de France et c'est à lui donner
des instructions aux banques voilà en
quelque sorte et pour ne pas longer mon
propos et pouvoir me prêter aux
questions si vous le souhaitez les
principaux enseignements que je tire
donc à la fois c'est 2 milliards 500
millions disponibles sur les quatre
premières années qui vont permettre
immédiatement d'investir et de l'argent
sur
la mise en condition opérationnelle de
nos forces armées de les mettre à niveau
de renforcer leur entraînement de leur
donner tous les moyens nécessaires et
puis aussi renforcement du contrôle
parlementaire avec notamment cette
commission d'évaluation de la politique
d'exportation et aussi un souci vers nos
entreprises de la BITD les plus petites
et les moyennes les ETI toutes celles et
ceux qui ont besoin de notre de notre
soutien voilà chers amis pour avoir des
idées assez claires et précises de ce
que j'espère nous allons entériner
demain
dans à travers le vote qui interviendra
pour approuver les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire je dois dire
que même si ceci a donné lieu à des
moments non pas de tension mais en tous
les cas d'échange qui est tout à fait
normal tout ça s'est passé dans un dans
un bon climat avec les discussions les
interruptions nécessaires y compris
nocturne mais qui ont fait que
on a beaucoup investi de notre temps et
notre sommeil mais j'ai été je dois dire
et je reste personnellement très fier de
d'avoir pu porter le rapport de cette
loi de programmation militaire qui j'en
suis persuadé fera qu'en 2030 nos forces
armées seront un peu plus musclées un
peu plus tonique un petit peu avec un
peu plus de moyens et pour affronter des
défis de la sécurité qui ne cesse
malheureusement de se poser à nous
notamment à partir de la situation qui
sévit en
Ukraine comme vous le savez et qui ne
s'arrange guère et pour ne pas dire qui
s'aggrave deux jours en jours voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs chers amis
journalistes que je voulais dire et
maintenant je me prête bien évidemment
aux questions si vous en avez
monsieur Gabirol que je suis heureux de
saluer
merci Michel Cabirol la tribune juste
une clarification alors je suis c'est
vrai que je suis arrivé en retard je
m'en excuse par avance
sur la clarification des 13 milliards de
recettes extra budgétaires ce que vous
avez des des
certitudes après les discussions que
vous avez avec le gouvernement ça c'est
un premier point et deuxième point vous
avez évoqué effectivement le livret de
souveraineté qui s'est transformé en
tout cas via le livret A en une aide
pour la BITD notamment pour la les PME
et les ETI de les startups évidemment ça
concerne uniquement les entreprises de
défense mais quand vous dites
entreprises de défense c'est en général
des entreprises duales donc juste une
clarification sur ce sur le thème de
enfin sur la précision entreprise de
défense
alors sur la sur la première question je
je redis comment nous avons apprécié ces
13 milliards c'est 13 milliards en fait
était une annonce qui
résultait me semble-t-il d'une
négociation très compliquée qui a été
intervenu dans la préparation de cet LPM
entre le gouvernement le ministre Bercy
et donc c'était une présentation
j'allais dire un peu
amélioré
des choses en divisant enfin en
présentant 13 milliards supplémentaires
de recettes extra budgétaires ces
recettes extra budgétaires contre
lesquelles le Parlement d'une manière
générale n'est pas très favorable pour
lesquelles le Parlement n'est pas très
favorable alors ces recettes extra
budgétaires se divisées en deux 5
milliards 9
je dis bien 5 milliards 9 de recettes
extra budgétaires à peu près identifier
je le rappelle les ventes immobilières
du du secteur des armées les ventes de
fréquences
et puis les produits de l'activité
hospitalière et médicale des armées
puisque les hôpitaux militaires
reçoivent aussi des populations civiles
qui payent évidemment des redevances et
des soins et bon on pouvait absolument
on aurait pu du rester là et dire 400
milliards plus 5 milliards 9 disons que
les la conversation aurait été plus
facile tout au long des débats à cela
s'ajoutait donc plus de 7 milliards 7
milliards 4 c'est si je fais compter sur
mes doigts 7 milliards quatre
de recettes extra budgétaires non
identifiées alors dans l'esprit du
gouvernement et on va pas reprendre avec
le gouvernement la polémique sur ce
sujet dans l'esprit du gouvernement il
s'agissait de de produits qui est
proviennent des reports de charges et de
ce qu'on appelle les marges
frictionnelles pour parler dans un
langage à peu près cohérent c'est les
retards de programme c'est à dire
effectivement si vous commandez
un Airbus ou un Rafale et qui n'est pas
livré à temps le programme peut être
déplacé déporté d'une année de 6 mois il
y a toujours des événements dans une loi
de programmation militaire qui fait que
tous les femmes ne sont pas exactement
n'arrivent pas en temps et en heure et
donc si vous si vous commandez un Airbus
un A400M qui n'est pas livré par
définition vous ne le payez pas donc la
somme est reportée donc ce sont des
reports de charges tout à fait classique
dans la ville d'entreprise on connaît ça
nous ne contestons pas ce point ce point
et nous pensons effectivement qu'il y
aura des rapports de des reports de
charges et il y aura des marges
frictionnelles mais si vous voulez nous
nous ne les considérions pas au cours de
ces discussions et nos sentiments
demeure les considérons pas comme des
recettes qu'il convient que l'on peut
avancer qui couvre des dépenses si elles
arrivent tant mieux et ça améliorera le
le régime des forces armées qu'on a bien
besoin depuis plus de 25 ans
déraintement mais on est pour nous ce ne
sont pas des des ressources si je vous
donne si je vous dis que je vous fais un
cadeau de de 100 euros et puis que je
vous en donne 80 et je vous dis mais il
y aura 20 euros qui arriveront vous me
direz les 20 euros je les ai pas dans ma
poche c'est un petit peu ce raisonnement
que nous avons appliqué donc ça c'est
effectivement la part
qui était vraiment le fondement de notre
discussion le ministre a donné ses
données beaucoup de mal pour tenter de
nous convaincre mais on a eu quelques
difficultés à bien comprendre on est
peut-être beaucoup moins intelligents
mais toujours est-il que
ce n'est pas dans notre perception des
choses d'identifier dans une autre
programme des recettes qui n'ont pas de
véritables
de véritables compléments 400 milliards
ça c'est des recettes budget
c'est-à-dire ce sont des crédits de
paiement tout le monde connaît bien la
distinction entre les autorisations de
programme et les crédits de paiement moi
j'ai fait ça en tant que mère et quand
je voulais avoir des effets de séance
j'annonçais des autorisations de
programme et comme j'avais pas l'argent
n'allez pas fait tellement au bout du
projet donc voilà sur ce sujet alors en
ce qui concerne les en ce qui concerne
le financement de la BTD
on laisse le gouvernement avec son
chiffre 400 413 si vous voulez alors
selon que selon que vous acceptez la
première version j'allais dire
budgétaire au sens strict du terme nous
on prend 400 milliards de crédit de
paiement et puis le gouvernement peut
toujours dire qu'il peut y en a 13 je
rappelle tout de même un élément que je
l'ai pas signalé tout dans ce propos
liminaire mais que dans ce budget on est
enfin le gouvernement
identifie
le
niveau de l'inflation la perte en
inflation à 30 milliards 30 milliards ce
qui est absolument considérable donc
quand vous fixez un chiffre pareil
d'inflation j'entendais ce matin les
premières nouvelles qui nous est que
l'inflation a tendance à diminuer tant
mieux tant mieux ça veut dire que cet
argent pourra permettre l'acquisition de
nouveaux équipements et donc ça ça ira
dans le bon sens mais on pense
effectivement que ces recettes extra
budgétaires comme leur nom l'indique
elles n'ont été revendiquées comme telle
par le ministre elle était pouv ait pas
être dans le budget donc on les
appartenus mais on les laisse dans la
communication du gouvernement comme
étant une hypothèse bénéfique pour les
forces pour les forces armées
crédit budgétaire il lui fallut dans ce
cas là apporter l'argent et ce n'était
pas manifestement dans le projet du
gouvernement dans le cadre de la future
loi de programme des finances publiques
parce que si vous mettez des recettes
budgétaires dans ce cas là voilà il faut
mettre des impôts ou alors comme nos
collègues socialistes à lui proposer
faut taxer les assurances vie enfin vous
voyez il faut trouver des faut trouver
des éléments concrets comme on les a pas
trouvé on laisse cette communication 400
413 s'il est 13 viennent tant mieux s'il
y en a même 15 ou 18 ce sera encore
beaucoup mieux et si on a un peu moins
d'inflation ce sera le bonheur absolu et
ça voudra dire qu'on rattrapera le temps
que l'on a perdu mais ce que l'on veut
nous c'est des engagements concrets
parce que nos forces armées ont perdu
beaucoup et ça a été toujours dans les
lois de programmation militaire
précédente ça a toujours été là où le
gouvernement récupéré une partie de ce
qu'il avait donné c'est toujours sur le
MCO sur la mise en condition
opérationnelle parce que c'était assez
facile ça ne se voyait pas beaucoup et
par définition les militaires sont très
disciplinés donc
personne ne protestait mais donc là on
s'est livré un exercice de vérité
budgétaire et je crois que ça va dans le
bon sens et nos collègues nos collègues
de l'Assemblée nationale n'ont pas été
insensibles me semble-t-il à ce travail
de vérité que nous avons effectué alors
en ce qui concerne le financement de la
BITD notamment sur les petites et
moyennes entreprises pour l'instant
c'est une décision de principe qui
durait pour lequel on s'est donné deux
années d'expérimentation pour voir si
effectivement on entrait dans ce
dispositif alors au jour d'aujourd'hui
rien n'a été véritablement précisé sur
les entreprises duales mais nous ce qui
nous importe c'est que ce soit la partie
évidemment défense de ces entreprises
qui puissent bénéficier d'un financement
et ce sont des entreprises françaises
cela va sans dire
alors chez nos amis qui sont en visio et
ce qu'il y a d'autres questions
et j'étais si clair
sur la partie
exportation donc le droit donné au
Parlement de de regarder en tout cas de
pas contrôler mais en tout cas de
constater en tout cas le les licences
d'exportation évidemment on est dans un
régime ou tout le monde joue le jeu mais
le c'est pas n'est-ce pas la porte
ouverte à
des dérives éventuellement de de groupe
parlementaires de dévoiler certaines
choses enfin certains certaines
commandes ou certaines licences qui
seraient susceptibles d'être je dirais
polémique
je pense que le danger existe bien
évidemment car une autre programmation
militaire qui s'étale sur ces temps ne
préjuge pas ne serait-ce que des
résultats des élections législatives qui
interviendront au milieu de la de la loi
de programmation militaire j'ose croire
néanmoins que de part et d'autre au
Sénat j'en suis sûr à l'Assemblée je
l'espère la raison l'emportera car bien
évidemment personne n'oublie que les
exportations d'armes c'est une activité
économique très importante je rappelle
qu'elles font vivre plus de 200 000
salariés en France et donc il faut que
le Parlement se limite j'allais presque
dire constitutionnellement à ses
pouvoirs ce n'est pas le ce ne sont pas
les pouvoirs du Parlement de participer
à l'attribution des licences nous sommes
mis aux États-Unis ni dans d'autres pays
européens nous avons une tradition qui
donne à l'exécutif une une compétence
importante en revanche le Parlement doit
être doit pouvoir évaluer cette
politique et pouvoir conseiller le
gouvernement comme nous le faisons sur
la délégation parlementaire
renseignement si je prends l'expérience
de la DPA à laquelle j'ai l'honneur de
siéger depuis quelques années je dois
dire que c'est un
quel que soit les sensibilités or vous
savez que ce sont des commissions qui
font la place aux différentes
sensibilités et donc il y a des élus qui
siègent de différents groupes alors il y
a certains ne sont pas représentés c'est
un fait mais les les groupes qui sont
représentés au sein de cette DPR ont
toujours absolument jouer
appliquer les règles absolues de
confidentialité qui conviennent je
rappelle que même au sein de la
délégation parlementaire d'enseignement
nous avons la Commission de vérification
des fonds spéciaux donc vous imaginez je
veux dire la le côté le côté
particulièrement confidentiel qu'il peut
y avoir parce que cela pourrait mettre
en jeu y compris la vie de nos de nos
propres agents qui sont à l'étranger
donc il y a des règles et du reste nous
sommes soumis à des contrôles et à des
règles qui
que l'on ne peut pas sur lequel on ne
peut pas transiger donc j'ose croire que
ce dispositif restera dans l'esprit qui
est celui qui est proposé à savoir une
commission d'évaluation c'est le rôle du
Parlement d'évaluer les politiques
publiques c'est les presque dire c'est
un rôle constitutionnellement reconnu
d'autres questions je vois des amis
journalistes à l'écran oui
oui je vous en prie bonjour monsieur
sénateur deux questions
quel bilan vous faites sur le les volets
cyber relatives à longs
[Musique]
de précision par rapport au rapport sur
la cyberdéfense des dessinateurs Cadic
et Valais qui devaient être publiés qui
n'a pas été pas encore été publié voilà
est-ce que vous en savez les raisons
sur la première question ils vont être
publiés je crois qu'il y a un léger
retard technique d'impression et nous
avons plusieurs rapports plusieurs
rapports qui sont qui font l'objet d'un
petit délai de publication parce que en
fin de session toutes les commissions
évidemment ce matin nous avons voté par
exemple 3 rapports excessivement
passionnants et j'espère que vous les
lire avec attention et qui ne seront
peut-être pas imprimés
ne seront pas imprimés dans les dans les
8 jours alors relatif aux relations avec
l'ancien
là il y a des précisions assez
techniques je veux juste reciter la la
validation que nous avons effectuée des
articles 32 à 35 relatifs à Nancy sans
modification par rapport au projet du
gouvernement il y avait la volonté
effectivement
notamment vis-à-vis d'un organisme de la
CND
la cndtr excusez-moi la fatigue aidant
dans un autre je me perds dans les
acronymes bon il y avait une volonté de
la cndtr de de procéder à la saisie de
donner y compris à distance de ces
organismes qui sont ce qui est tout à
fait compréhensible attentif à ne pas
être l'objet de contrôle qui pour
l'instant sont plutôt bien exercés par
les organismes d'état et en ce qui
concerne donc ce dispositif l'article 35
l'article 35 bis introduit que le Sénat
introduit va obliger Lancy à faire un
rapport au Parlement sur le filtrage des
noms de domaine Internet donc vous voyez
qu'il y a il y a tout de même toujours
le même souci d'information du Parlement
mais sans mettre en cause ces organismes
de la même manière il y a une longue
discussion sur la la reconnaissance
la labilitation voilà la l'habilitation
que l'on souhaitait donner il ne fallait
pas non plus Lancy nous avait fait part
de la nécessité de ne pas alourdir le
dispositif actuel ce sont des agents qui
ont des habilitations déjà il n'était
pas nécessaire de renforcer de compléter
ce dispositif ça a été des discussions
assez délicates mais je dois dire que
nos collègues et notamment ceux qui
représentent la cnctr ont très vite
compris que tout renforcement de ces
dispositifs d'abord nécessité des
aménagements techniques excessivement
compliqués qui de toute façon n'aurait
rendu aucun dispositif utilisable avant
2025 donc là je pense qu'il va y avoir
demain dans la déclaration du ministre
quelques éléments qui devraient nous
être délivrés sur tout ce chapitre
concernant le renseignement le rôle de
la cnctr j'ai demandé au ministre de
préciser ces intentions de telle sorte
qu'il puisse à la fois rassurer les les
intervenants qui sont venus sur ces
amendements et mon sentiment personnel
est que effectivement
au moins un débat si ce n'est une loi
dans ces domaines devra intervenir et ne
pas modifier des équilibres qui existent
actuellement à la faveur d'amendement
dans une loi de programme c'est des
sujets qui sont très importants et qui
mettent aussi en cause la protection des
libertés et vous savez combien le Sénat
est attentif à ce point
alors une autre faites un petit geste
que je vois si vous êtes je vous vois à
l'écran mais je ne
d'autres questions
profitez-en parce que après
demain ce sera trop tard
oui bonjour bonjour monsieur le
Président moi j'avais une petite
question sur les cibles il y avait eu un
amendement capacitaire qui avait été
assez remarqué dans la production du
Sénat si j'ai bien compris cette cet
amendement était passé par perdre des
profits est-ce que vous avez des regrets
sur les grandes sites capacitaires de
cet LPM je pensais notamment au segment
de la défense solaire quand on voit que
on va rester horizon 2030 à 8 systèmes
santé et 9 20 Mika on se rend compte que
projeter une division avec aussi peu de
stocks ça relève peut-être un petit peu
d'équilibré
ne vous laissez pas un goût un petit peu
amer sur ses cibles qui sont quand même
assez modestes sur beaucoup de segments
merci beaucoup
alors évidemment ce point a été
longuement discuté à la fois par nos
rapporteurs dans la préparation de la
LPM et au cours du débat et vous savez
que j'avais moi-même déposé un
amendement 305 si mes souvenirs sont
bons un amendement 10 capacitaire qui
justement
visait à obtenir des engagements de la
part de l'État sur l'accroissement d'un
certain nombre d'équipements qui nous
semblent effectivement insuffisants par
rapport au contexte international je
pense évidemment au programme scorpion
par exemple qui était absolument
prioritaire dans la précédente LPM et
que et qui a sensiblement ralenti je
pense au rafales je pense aux
hélicoptères les hélicoptères à chiels
qui passent 267 à 20 évidemment c'est ça
peut paraître assez surprenant parce que
les hélicoptères interarmes sont des
équipements absolument nécessaires alors
bien évidemment quand est intervenu la
discussion et la volonté de compromis il
a fallu faire des choix et c'est vrai
que après avoir pris la tâche du
président du Sénat et en liaison avec
les différents groupes nous avons
préféré
n'ont pas lâcher mais en tous les cas
moins
identifié dans ces dans cette dans cette
LPM les
tous les toutes les prévisions
capacitaires parce que nous avons
considéré que tout ce qui est relevé du
MCO était beaucoup plus prioritaire que
d'avoir effectivement tel ou telle
équipement en plus grand nombre ça ne
veut pas dire ça ne veut pas dire que
nous considérons que ce sont des
préoccupations mineures alors bien
évidemment il faut aussi comprendre
comment cette loi a été construite car
comme vous le soulignez très justement
cette loi de programmation militaire
crée un effet optique qui est un petit
peu agaçant au sens où on s'est félicité
et je me félicite bien évidemment de
cette augmentation de plus de 100
milliards qui est quand même
considérable dans le contexte
budgétaire actuel et pour nombre de
programmes ça aboutit à une forme de
ralentissement des commandes alors on
peut on peut l'expliquer de différentes
manières j'ai évoqué tout à fait déjà
l'inflation le fait que ces équipements
beaucoup plus technologiques que ceux
qui le remplacent sont aussi beaucoup
plus coûteux un Rafale coûte beaucoup
plus cher
un mirage un
scorpion coûte évidemment beaucoup plus
cher qu'un AMX-10 et on peut
démultiplier ainsi et donc je pense que
il était préférable d'abord l'exécutif
était était assez hostile en
contestant en quelque sorte la
compétence du Parlement pour fixer
ligne après ligne ces objectifs
capacitaires mais au-delà de ça nous
avons fait ce choix de faire le geste
qui consistait à retirer cet abonnement
ce que j'ai fait afin de pouvoir nouer
l'accord qui va donner la LPM en faisant
encore une fois ces 2 milliards 300
millions de crédit supplémentaires sur
l'entraînement parce que ça nous semble
encore plus essentiel que le reste à
quoi servirait d'entasser des engins
blindés ou des avions dans les hangars
s'il y a personne pour les servir et je
crois que c'est ça le cœur de notre
réflexion et c'est ça le cœur de notre
rapport c'est à dire de notre apport et
non pas de nos rapports
les autres apports pour dire
une armée doit être bien entraînée
effectivement il lui faut les matériels
qui conviennent mais
on ne peut pas raisonner en capacité à
permanente je sais qu'il y a eu des
réactions il y a eu des commentaires il
y a eu des tribunes qui ont dit mais
c'est insuffisance c'est toujours
insuffisant bien évidemment
nos forces armées se seraient
rattraperait encore plus vite leur
retard si on avait 450 ou 500 milliards
mais tel n'est pas la situation est-elle
ne permet pas la situation budgétaire
donc dans ce cas-là quand on se dirige
vers un compromis il faut que chacun
fasse un pas le pas du Parlement a été
de renoncer à l'identification de d'une
d'un accroissement en capacitaire pour
privilégier l'entraînement de nos forces
armées qui à travers toutes les visites
tous les rapports toutes les auditions
nous montrent à l'évidence que il y a là
un très gros déficit et du reste les
témoignage que je reçois depuis la CMP
de témoignages de force armées montrent
que le Sénat était véritablement dans le
bon sens
d'accord est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions
auxquelles vous souhaitez que je réponde
bon est-ce que vous avez des
regrets j'ai toujours des regrets mais
j'ai des éléments de cette j'ai d'abord
des éléments de satisfaction je le redis
100 milliards de plus il est absolument
considérable et ne boudons pas notre
plaisir ne vous donnons pas notre
plaisir mais vous savez ayant un peu
d'expérience de cette affaire dans la
maison j'ai aussi vécu des lois de
programmation militaire qui suivaient
une pente absolument descendante parce
que paraît-il à l'époque il fallait
tirer les dividendes de la paix on a vu
ce que ça a donné donc j'ai des éléments
de satisfaction j'ai l'élément de
satisfaction de pouvoir conclure cette
loi de programmation militaire parce que
on peut aussi imaginer les conséquences
qu'auraient eu le fait de ne pas se
mettre d'accord et de repousser à plus
loin dans le temps puisque à la fois les
vacances parlementaires mais aussi les
élections au Sénat tout ça va repousser
le calendrier je pense qu'il n'était pas
à la fois il n'était pas nécessaire de
de gêner le chef des armées dans cette
affaire mais il fallait que le Parlement
soit respecté et moi ce que ma
satisfaction c'est que les analyses que
nous avons fait tout au long des
rapports tout au long du travail de
fonds que l'on fait ces analyses ont
prévalu elles ont prévalu non seulement
auprès de l'Assemblée nationale et je
remercie encore une fois leur apporteur
et le président de la commission mais
ils ont elles ont prévalu auprès du
gouvernement qui a entendu le signal qui
était qui était donné et je pense que
sur les éléments les plus saillants que
ce soit cette augmentation des
demi-heure 3 ou que soit la première
commission d'évaluation des licences
d'exportation je pense que ce sont des
éléments qui convient de mettre au
crédit du Sénat ça a été fait du reste
dans vos différents organes de presse
c'est pas pour en tirer fierté c'est que
simplement on a le sens du devoir
accompli et c'est le sentiment qui
m'anime à l'instant que je vous parle
on peut dire les choses comme ça
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions je
vous remercie toutes et tous merci de
votre attention c'est important vous
savez le rapport que les médias vont en
faire parce que il faut que l'opinion
publique puisse comprendre cet effort
une crise sociale de grande importance a
tourné autour de 16 ou 17 milliards au
moment des retraits là on est à 413
milliards alors bien évidemment sur 7
ans et non pas annuellement je précise
parce que des fois c'est mal compris
mais je pense qu'il était plus que
jamais nécessaire que c'est toi
intervienne à un moment que nous n'avons
pas cherché à créer mais que de
d'immense tensions au cœur de l'Europe
jusqu'à présent nous avions cette armée
corps expéditionnaire en quelque sorte
qui répondait aux mandat que lui donnait
les Nations unies ou que
nécessitait l'application d'accord
de défense que nous avions notamment en
Afrique bon maintenant il y a un paysage
tout à fait nouveau qui qui s'ouvre et
c'est notre propre sécurité qui peut
être mise demain en cause et on le voit
constamment par des déclarations somme
tout assez belliqueuse
de la Russie ce qui est bien dommage
venant d'un pays aussi important que que
la Russie mais il faut se préparer et
mon devoir de rapporteur le devoir de
mes collègues c'est de d'avoir aider le
gouvernement et le chef de l'État à
prendre les bonnes décisions à un moment
ou plus que jamais nous avons besoin de
renforcer nos
forces qui sont admirables qui ont
rempli qui ont rempli d'émissions
absolument
extraordinaires mais il était temps de
s'interroger on n'a pas totalement
répondu à la question sur le modèle
d'armée que nous souhaitions car ça
nécessitait peut-être des débats plus
approfondis des échanges un peu plus
nourris mais en tous les cas je pense
que nous sommes arrivés à un bon
compromis qui au fil des exercices
budgétaires va se je l'espère se
concrétiser je dois dire à la vérité que
la précédente LPM qui est encore en
cours tant que cette loi programme n'est
pas
encore promulgués et s'applique au 1er
janvier prochain c'est à dire que on
peut reconnaître au gouvernement malgré
les turbulences budgétaires que cette
loi a été régulièrement la précédente
loi enfin celle qui fonctionne encore
maintenant a été strictement appliqué et
je pense que il faut arrêter les
rincements de nos forces armées car on
la France a une position qui est
respectée nous avons des engagements
internationaux nous sommes membres du
Conseil de sécurité nous sommes attendus
sur tous les océans et dans de nombreux
pays et pour ça notre responsabilité de
donner les moyens aux forces armées
c'est la responsabilité du politique et
il y a trop de menaces actuellement pour
que nos forces armées n'aient pas les
moyens d'agir merci à tous
à votre disposition et puis demain
résultat final vote de la commission mix
paritaire merci